rache vor gericht hier rastet ein vater
aus und attackierte mörder seines sohnes
im gerichtssaal im us bundesstaat ohio
des sean brown ist wegen zweifachen
mordes angeklagt er soll seine freundin
erstochen und ihren sohn aus einer
früheren beziehung lebendig in einen
fluss geworfen haben der dreijährige
wurde nie gefunden
ebenfalls im gerichtssaal and only bios
der leibliche vater des jungen zuerst
sitzt er noch ruhig in der letzten reihe
doch dann hält das ihn nicht mehr auf
seinem platz er stürmt auf brown zu und
fängt an auf ihn einzuschlagen es
braucht zwei polizeibeamtinnen um jungs
von dem angeklagten wegzubekommen auch
einer der anwälte versucht ihn zu
beruhigen
doch hughes ist aufgebracht immer mehr
beamte kommen dazu schaffen es aber kaum
den wütenden vater in schach zu halten
schließlich werden erst der angeklagte
und dann sein angreifer in handschellen
aus dem saal geführt
der zwischenfall hat konsequenzen für
antonia user wurde wegen missachtung des
gerichts zu sieben tagen haft verurteilt
und auf dass sean brown sitzt weiterhin
im gefängnis freunde des opfers
berichten die frau sei von ihm schwanger
gewesen habe aber eine fehlgeburt
erlitten brown soll daraufhin damit
gedroht haben ihrem sohn aus einer
früheren beziehung etwas anzutun ihm
droht jetzt die todesstrafe
[Musik]